durante os 10 anos de idade
eu fiz uma maquete de uma hidrelétrica
preferências do colégio e eu cheguei
basquete muito chata
eu fui falar com meu pai de espalha só
eu queria lá pelas tantas no meio da
minha explicação eu pudesse ligar
mauzinho nem mostrar às pessoas que de
fato da usina hidrelétrica servia para
gerar energia
olhou pra mim estabelecidos quero ligar
uma luzinha tu tem que saber montar um
circuito elétrico
ele disse que o circuito elétrico
funcionava essencialmente da mesma forma
que o circuito de fórmula 1 onde o carro
sai da linha de largada percorre toda a
pista vai até a linha de chegada e
formar formas em um circuito fechado
se você quer fazer isso com uma pilha
uns fiozinhos e uma lâmpada eu ia
conseguir ascender eu parei e pensei um
pouquinho lei
ontem as coisas até porque não tinha
muita opção né pasmem
a lâmpada ligou e que nunca teve
experiência de ligar uma lâmpada dessa
forma por favor tente realmente muito
diferente do que simplesmente apertar o
interruptor era uma criança que tinha
alguma aptidão né pra coisas elétricas e
quando eu crescer um pouquinho foi
escolher o curso pra fazer na faculdade
eu pude escolher entre qualquer curso do
universo desde que fosse engenharia e
qualquer engenharia desde que fosse
elétrica
mas foi o curso que eu entrei depois
acabei tocando na engenharia de produção
eu considero um sujeito bastante sorte
eu sempre gosto de falar que a gente
precisa dar oportunidade para a sorte
acontecer eu estava fazendo só a coisa
certa no lugar certo no momento certo
o dia que o professor gustavo vez me
convidou para a aula de cálculo no curso
de você pode passar a idéia de que
alguma coisa para pessoas extremamente
sérias mas não mas o tanque não é sobre
gustavo é o ponto é sobre um cara
chamado renan que era o cara que vai
substituir é por isso que estava sendo
contratado que assim como era estudante
de engenharia e um estudante de direito
civil que estava prestes a se formar e
eu ia passar a as aulas de cálculo que
lhe dava antes eu estava lá no dia que o
transformou
simples estudante de engenharia ele se
tornou o engenheiro foi contratado por
uma ótima empresa e para ajudar aulas
está vendo tudo muito bem até ali até o
dia que resolvi perguntar o que eu ia
fazer quando me formar e no auge da
minha reflexão e encontro não tinha a
menor idéia do que queria fazer mas que
basicamente estava acontecendo duas
coisas em paralelo de um lado eu estava
fazendo um curso de engenharia e
futuramente assim como renan também
seria um profissional cobiçado no
mercado
do outro lado estava dando aula mas
enfim eu resolvi parar de pensar muito
naquilo e até porque se eu tivesse
pensado muito talvez não tivesse feito a
maioria das coisas que eu fiz e resolvi
mergulhar de cabeça nesse mundo de
educação de dar aulas sem pensar muito
mesmo
a primeira pergunta que me passou foi
justamente o quanto as pessoas aprendem
ou porque as pessoas aprendem
nós aprendemos muito mais por inspiração
do que qualquer outra coisa
a gente se inspira as pessoas que nós
admiramos nas habilidades que nós
gostaríamos de ter
e são essas somatória de inspirações que
vão formando a nossa identidade pessoal
aprender qualquer coisa também exige
muito trabalho duro muito ao muitas
horas sentado refletindo pensando e
tentando enxergar o que aquilo ali vai
fazer diferença na nossa vida mas no
foco de todo esse processo educacional
educação uma coisa está muito em foco
hoje em dia não é uma figura é figura do
professor é fazer uma aposta com vocês
eu aposto que ganhar todos nós lembramos
de pelo menos três professores que nós
tivemos durante a vida e pensa sempre
lembrar de três professores pelo menos
rapidamente que marcaram a sua vida e
esses professores de alguma forma mesmo
que você nem lembro que foi o conteúdo
que aprendeu com ele de alguma forma
eles marcaram a sua vida né fala em
educação é bastante complicado e
conceitual que a educação é muito
complicado principalmente é muito
complicado diferença na educação de
treinamento mas exatamente por isso que
hoje se eu pudesse dar um pitaco sobre o
que é educação educação pra mim é
praticamente um sinônimo de trabalho em
equipe e é muito importante que a gente
frise que nós não temos dificuldade
criar pequenos núcleos educacionais que
oferecem serviços de alta qualidade que
forma em pessoas com alto potencial
nós temos dificuldade de dar escala à
educação de qualidade e por favor
a educação tem a ver com a base da
sociedade com todo com todo o
desenvolvimento da sociedade é o congo
que a educação mexe enfrentar problemas
como saúde problemas do meio ambiente
problema de da das cidades é muito mais
difícil e um país e uma sociedade que
não preza pela educação de qualidade
para todo mundo não tem futuro para o
país sem educação de qualidade em si não
é uma coisa muito complicada né eu
acredito que ensinar seja uma das
habilidades mais triviais mais naturais
do ser humano
afinal de contas a gente chegou até aqui
nós desenvolvemos como espécie
justamente pela nossa capacidade de
disseminar o conhecimento entre os
nossos semelhantes e perpetuar esse
conhecimento através das gerações
isso não é uma coisa tão difícil assim
mas ensinar alguns pequenos diferenciais
e tem pessoas que têm uma coisa que se
chama didática conceituado da tática de
uma forma didática é muito difícil é
muito complicado mas algumas coisas que
acontecem na nossa vida alguns pontos
que vão acontecendo que quando acontece
a gente não se dá conta muito porque o
simplesmente não não entende naquele
momento mas depois olhando para trás
eles se tornam claro e fazem todas fazem
toda a diferença e eu passei um bom
tempo na minha vida estudando música
clássica tentei ser um violonista
clássico e pra mim didática é uma frase
for ver bem expressado por uma frase de
um dos maiores violonistas que já
conheci que orgulham brin paixão e
desejo pra comunicar esse é o ponto isso
pra mim é didática né eu acredito que
didática é aquilo que as pessoas
percebem de você e não aquilo que você
acha que está fazendo e focando
principalmente de didática que eu
resolvi começar um projeto enfim eu
resolvi começar não é bem a expressão
porque ele não é de uma forma totalmente
espontânea
nem eu comecei a colocar minhas aulas na
internet colocar fazer um projeto de um
nome bastante carismático pra ele salva
ea ii nasceu em uma plataforma
educacional que foca principalmente em
didática né
basicamente o que a gente faz hoje é
selecionar estudantes que têm alto
potencial didático para registrar a
produzir aulas que vale a pena assistir
aulas que focam em didática acima do fim
de conhecimento de novo na didática eu
quero que as pessoas percebem de ti e
não aquilo que você acha que está
fazendo
tá aí falando bastante em aulas em vídeo
na aula em vídeo estão por todos os
lados e agora só se fala nisso
a pergunta é aulas em vídeo funciona não
sei
sai às vezes sim às vezes não tá e foi
bastante interessante e um dia estava eu
e alguns colegas me desculpando que
seriam as ferramentas que serão ideais
né não está pensando em gráficos
obviamente passar de carro não é e nem
as ferramentas ideais para medir o
desempenho das nossas aulas e como num
passe de mágica assim literalmente como
num passe de mágica uma semana depois do
google lançou exatamente as ferramentas
que a gente tinha pensado assim foi
bastante interessante e aqui esse é um
gráfico que mostra a retenção de uma
pessoa dentro de um de uma aula em vídeo
é uma aula de cálculo ensino superior
rapidamente aqui não vou nem uma de
professor de matemática explica gráfico
aqui mas enfim na nota vermelha o início
do vídeo todas as pessoas que abriram
vídeo 100% das pessoas e ao decorrer
desse gráfico aqui nós vamos vendo sobre
a linha azul quantas pessoas ainda
permanecem assistir a essa hora
e nessa aula que nós temos uma retenção
média de quase 60 por cento quase 60%
das pessoas assistiram à aula até o fim
é o maior orgulho hoje e dizer que em
média as aulas do projeto salva são
assistidas por até o final por mais da
metade das pessoas
isso é uma coisa que mexe bastante com a
gente enfim eu gosto bastante de números
né
só depois que a gente se deu conta ao
responder a primeira pergunta se as
aulas em vídeo funcionava a gente se deu
conta que funcionava a antiga nos
perguntar por que elas funcionam
não sei
só que dessa vez a gente começou a pisar
em território totalmente desconhecido
território totalmente novo onde o
professor de carro não conseguia fazer
mais gráficos para mid explicar essas
coisas mas foi aí que surge mais alguns
pontos na vida
quando a gente olha pra lá atrás a gente
se dá conta por que eles aconteceram
eu tive a oportunidade de assistir à
palestra do que robson pela internet
mesmo onde ele disse que a educação não
é um sistema mecânico educação o sistema
humano é sobre pessoas que podem querer
aprender ou não né isso precisa chegar
alguma coisa educação é sobre pessoas
nem toda a gente consegue explicar algum
tempo atrás a gente preparou as pessoas
com a idéia de que se ao longo da vida
devia preparar um currículo basicamente
um pedaço de papel que dizia todas as
coisas que você já fez as habilidades
que você tem e aqui não seria o
suficiente pra você com seu emprego ou
uma determinada posição mas hoje não dá
muito mais criativo mundo é muito mais
amplo e além do currículo das
habilidades você tem um mercado de
trabalho e as soluções que vão fazer a
diferença no mundo daqui pra frente
passam também pela criatividade ea
iniciativa das pessoas e resolver os
problemas nessas soluções criativas com
iniciativa que vão ser o diferencial na
no mundo daqui pra frente
mas enfim já que a gente mudou essa
concepção né de uma época onde era mais
velho para a mente é necessário ter um
currículo pra onde a gente precisa de
criatividade iniciativa para resolver os
problemas porque as escolas porque as
faculdades enfim deveriam preparar as
pessoas hoje não sei mas pela primeira
vez eu acho que não sei
é a resposta certa e eu tive a certeza
disso o ano passado quando tive a
oportunidade de assistir presencialmente
uma palestra do professor falconi em que
ele disse que hoje nós precisamos
preparar as pessoas para enfrentar o
desconhecido a cada dia isso possa ser
basicamente problema de vida enfim
aquela pergunta é o que eu vou fazer
quando me informar com certeza não sabia
hoje não tem a menor idéia
tá mas basicamente a minha vida mudou
bastante né eu ainda me conformado faz
engenharia de produção
e minha vida mudou bastante desde que eu
parei de enxergar o período de no nosso
período educacional como um período de
formação e passei a enxergar algo como
um período de transformação de um
momento onde está se preparando tudo
aquilo que isso ainda vai viver e como a
gente tem o prazer de contar com alguns
líderes que conseguem materializar em
frases aquilo que a gente não
necessariamente consegue enfim como já
disse steve jobs
a gente não pode ligar os pontos da
nossa vida olhando para o futuro nós só
podemos ligar os pontos nossa vida
olhando para trás e é por isso que a
gente tem que acreditar que de alguma
forma esses pontos vão se conectar lá no
futuro mostrando pra te onde está o
caminho ideal né entre elas pato a
paixão aquilo que realmente gosta de
fazer e onde é que estão as
oportunidades
[Aplausos]